foreign
as much as you know people like to hate
on Tick Tock there's some really
creative uh funny people out there
making some great content and one guy I
follow Matt bouchelle uh made one that
he walks through the streets of New York
with General observations this one is
about checking your bank account on
Monday and YOLO is the theme here so I
want you to see this for the first time
all right we'll get your reaction
every Monday I play my least favorite
game show it's called should I check my
bank account or should I just keep being
happy because no one wins it's kind of
scary I don't think 824 can make a
scarier movie than the moment when you
officially log in and see that credit
card number you're like like how much
have I racked up on this thing and the
second you see it it's always a little
too high so you're like well I will be
composing a strongly worded email to the
bank to let them know that uh fraud has
been committed on my account and then
you click it because all the pending
stuff now that it's Monday has gone
through to like pend it I guess is the
word and then you look at it you're like
let's see what happened here let's see
if I can find what happened like well
to go get dinner there and then uh yeah
I did go get drinks at that bar with
every and then yeah we did take that
Uber across town Kevin did Venom me ten
dollars for the 70 Uber so that's pretty
much fine and then uh yeah we did go to
that bar we did go to that but you're
like okay okay it's okay that's fine
then you see one thing you're like a
boogie company fifty dollars Boogie
company and you're like I got it I found
the fraud and then you remember in the
Uber you bought like a weird t-shirt
from an Instagram ad from a brand you've
never heard it like oh nope they got me
this time they got me it's so sad
there's nothing you can do you just have
to admit defeat close out of the bank
app go into Google and just type in like
how to actually cook dinner
okay so I get the Yola reference yes
yeah so he's walking through the average
kind of millennial gen Z's lifestyle and
they're going there's got to be fraud in
here somewhere I don't I didn't spend
all this money right and it turns out it
was the whole him at the end of the day
so he's a funny Creator and really Taps
into what people are feeling these days
which is I'm broke I have almost no
money in the bank but I want the
happiness on this side I want the YOLO I
want to go out with my friends I want to
enjoy my life and they feel like they
can't have both
and we know that's not true but we also
know it takes sacrifice and you can't go
out every weekend to all four bars and
go Uber all around town and buy anything
you want from Instagram and still have
money in the bank I'm gonna come up with
a new uh a new thing for this what is it
i2i oh no the letter I I know this I
number two and then I injury to insult
is what this practice is I'm gonna get
in I know I'm broke but I don't know how
I'm broke I know I'm broke but I've got
to go back and do this awful scavenger
hunt in my bank account and just keep
getting an injury and the insult it's an
old phrase it's terrible I hope Jensen
fix that one up again they're not going
to who came up with that one oh this 47
year old guy Ken Coleman yeah this old
Boomer is trying to wear a hoodie to
look cool next to George oh that's good
no but you understand what I'm saying
that's horrible oh the key is you know
exactly we know exactly what we're doing
to ourselves but we don't want to feel
any pain pain which by pain I mean
getting on a budget being intentional
saying no to friends having the
boundaries to say hey man I'm trying to
get out of debt I want to have more than
40 dollars in my bank account at any
given moment which means I'm going to be
side hustling driving for Uber instead
of getting into an Uber yeah and that's
a very different mentality and that's
what I had to do when I was getting out
of debt I drove for Uber and Lyft so I
was downtown Nashville on the weekends
Ken but I was doing it because I was
trying to make an extra 40 50 60 70 that
night to pay off debt here's one more
old man uh idea here on this if you're
spending you're young you're out hanging
out with everybody every night that food
and drink it better be really good
because you are fortunate you are kind
of forfeiting your future
um
uh you were delaying real Independence
real Financial Freedom all because you
want to go have you know not even that
good of an appetizer well they go well
can I cook this at home and I get this
feedback Ken well cooking at home is
it's even more expensive than eating out
goodness gracious because here's what
they do they go willy-nilly to the
grocery store get all this stuff they
can make one meal out of it throw the
rest away and then complain that 90 on
groceries is more expensive than forty
dollars on eating out yeah that makes no
sense you don't you ought to do will be
a fun video for you on Tick Tock and
YouTube is take some young gen's ears
that are single and working and take
them to Costco oh and literally shop for
you it would be my heart's Delight I
know you would love that wouldn't you
yes be good video like literally go okay
you know look I'm literally going to
shop for you for a month cut of food you
like and then you go on there and you're
gonna look this will last they tell me
their budget yes and we shop within that
budget yeah they think you're gonna work
miracles
man this is a great idea if any gen's
ears are open to hanging out with me and
going to Costco yeah let me know yeah at
George Campbell maybe Ken will tag along
we'll get some free samples yeah I tell
you what and I could just be the old guy
who eats the samples and comments on the
samples that's a good pot sticker right
there I'll tell you that right now I
don't know why I'm doing that the
content America needs yeah